si vous avez fréquenté la venue du
centre à montigny vendredi dernier vous
avez forcément aperçu ce message
clairement à poser sur les vitres de la
direction départementale du travail
sapin m'a tuer un message directement
adressé à michel sapin le ministre du
travail par les contrôleurs ils
craignent la disparition de leur corps
de métier comme nicolas chameau
contrôleurs du travail depuis 2007
aujourd'hui le ministre présente une
réforme qui vise à mettre en extinction
le corps du contrôleur du travail donc
c'est assez technique mais ça veut dire
que les contrôleurs du travail existant
aujourd'hui n'existeront plus dans dix
ans donc d'une certaine partie des
contrôleurs donc ça 140 sur toute la
france sur les 3600 pourront être
inspecteur d'ici trois ans et l'autre
partie va seront à voir distraction
c'est à dire mourront et donc d'ici
quelques années il y aura plus de
contrôleurs du travail en france des
contrôleurs du travail contre les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés et
des inspecteurs les entreprises de plus
de 50 salariés avec les craintes de les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
seront beaucoup moins contrôlé la
direction départementale du travail
compte 120 agents dont 15 inspecteurs et
30 contrôleur le 14 mai une mobilisation
régionale est prévue à paris